disease is this woman you know i mean
speaking of
pre-covenant style speaking of diseases
can you tell on my neck uh she sent me a
picture it was super red yesterday
oh my god so i've been eating everyone
every time i eat vegan food something
happens
i don't think that's it i guess that
might be every time
so i eat vegan food maybe a week ago and
immediately as it hit my body i had
diarrhea for like three hours what did
you eat
explain me this yeah it's called vegan
explain me this part though
yeah explain me let me just finish it
one of the vegan meals that you ate
was soba noodles right which gave me
diarrhea immediately
and then the other one you ate was
chickpea which is basically like hummus
right
yeah um so i ate the chickpea vegan
whatever it is and i'm fine i go
so about four hours later
i feel heat on my neck
right yeah and i start scratching my
neck but i don't know what it is i just
think that i'm having like um
some sort of maybe it was too hot in the
room or something
but also you're also sleeping so you're
sleeping in and out
you don't know exactly what it is when i
woke up
it looked like
it looked like what edward james almost
his face looked like in high school
oh i love him i know he's a great
athlete he's got all these pop marks
right so you know what i mean
yeah ray leota it's like my favorite
line from family guy
what when they call rayleigh yoda like a
decorative autumn squash
[Laughter]
that's funny yeah so and it it was all
over my neck
we sent gilbert a photo oh my god it was
so itchy and even last night i couldn't
sleep that well
because it's just every five minutes i
have to itch it
so um i have this rash so i think vegan
foods just doesn't
pizza i'm gonna stick with pizzas well
scientifically this
yeah i did tried it i tried it
scientifically i think
pizzas um chicken pot pies clam chowder
that's good for me
yeah v anything with a v in it you know
like vegetables or
vegan it just doesn't bode boiled my
body i have an allergic reaction to it
that was the case how come the 50 of
benadryl didn't work on you
it should have gotten rid of it like if
it was like a an allergic reaction
there should be it should have made it
feel better what do you think it is
this boy is so dirty he has a heat rash
you know when kids get the [ __ ] heat
rash on their neck like i used to get it
a lot when i played in the soil
like in the heat and the humidity in the
philippines oh that's just what we do
yeah where else are we gonna play okay
grass
grass soil you'd smash up gummamela
petals and try to make oil and stuff
whoa
yeah okay um so
yeah he has been in the garage for the
past six days
he collects dust in his neck and it's
been so hot here
there is no it's not the garage isn't
temperature controlled and he doesn't
shower all day
his hair is getting longer so it sticks
to his neck
um and i think that he just has a very
classic
dirty boy heat rash
yeah i um i have to get rid of my mullet
i think that could be it it's either
vegan food or my mullet
vegan food all day one of the two has to
go one of the two has to go
then no then i choose the vegan food
keep the mullet
but um it's it's morphed into a
mullet 3.0 you guys i don't think you
know quite what it looks like from the
front from
the front it yeah it it it wraps around
it gets so hot it wraps around my neck
like this maybe this
oh i don't like that i don't like it
touch it yeah yeah i think you should
put a little ponytail in the front there
can you tie it can you actually yeah
yeah
make it a look why do you look like the
chicks from a handmade tail
like like a necklace i have
yeah like braided in the front yeah
that'd be sick
it's i think i think i think it might be
this against my neck you're right
and the sweat and the heat and the heat
and the garage dust
yeah i think my next hairstyle is i want
to do a rat tail
this is what he wants to do he wants to
do the old school shaolin where it's
shaved here and then just like a little
patch of
what do you think of that i like that
completely bald and then just the
ponytail
maybe not bald but like you know we'll
figure it out but i want to do some sort
of rat taily kind of a thing
you know okay johnny yeah we'll talk to
johnny did you guys see the spider that
was on my neck
oh my god that thing was so big yeah
that was big huh we'll put a picture
right here because that was